-[sniffing]
-[dog barking]
Her scent is fresh. She's here.
If I could just get
my infrared mode to work…
[scanner whirring]
That's not right.
Damn it,
now everything's in black and white.
[gasps]
Her trail ends right…
[shimmering sound]
…here.
My fruit! My beautiful fruit!
[thrusters whooshing]
[Saki gasps]
Got you.
Don't touch me. You took my mom away.
You're monsters!
Oh, sweet child, you think that was us?
I got her.
[blaster whirring, fires]
[Saki grunts]
[all gasping]
[gasping]
[dynamic electronic music plays]
[shouting, gasps]
[blaster whirring, fires]
[grunts, panting]
Nowhere to go now.
Okay, one where to go.
Where is she?
In that wagon.
Or, uh, that one.
Or, no, that-- No.
-Do you smell anything?
-[Nikita] Fish. Only fish.
So, we lost her?
[grunts] You lost her.
[rapid beeping]
Ooh! My infrared's working.